Right okay well i'm harry freeman.
And i'm 48 and aquarian
and aquarian monkey in the chinese.
Way of looking at astrology.
And i now work as the director of psychiatric
services up in this part of the state
running a psychiatric unit and the
community services around here.
I've always been interested
in psychiatry those
that was my that's my career to
some extent my passion i guess.
And i came to the equerry
as first of all because of
my connection at the
time to student politics
which had taken a rather
theatrical sort of turn i think.
By the early 70s of course i was university
from 1960 to 67 in medical school.
And the moratoria about vietnam and
those sorts of things were happening.
When i was beginning my
internships as a medic.
So i was active in left wing politics
and still active to some extent
in as i said the more theatrical
parts of student politics consequently i
was good friends with with graham dunstan
and with various people
who were still on campus.
Even though i'd left campus and
so i was identified i sell far.
Identified myself with
that group of people who were
talking about the counterculture.
That was. A peculiar sort of
liaison i suppose between the left
and this rather more anarchy
whole group of people.
But i guess for me.
I right through medical school and even.
Then as a young doctor.
And certainly in the beginning
of my training in psychiatry.
I didn't have the same.
Connection to doctors as
many of my colleagues did
for some reason.
I couldn't make the sort of tribal
connection to the rest of the doctors
that a lot of people did not that i wasn't
a good doctor and highly regarded and.
And. Fond of the whole
idea of being a doctor.
But it certainly didn't satisfy a need
for a tribal connection which i felt
and which people like graham and.
The more active an interesting student
politicians did represent forming.
So. When in.
I suppose it was like 1970 to due
to my. Various pollution a journey.
Connections to graham. He talked about.
Doing a festival at
nimbin. I am mediately.
Said well i guess we all need some sort
of medical people there are you would
remember now you might not
remember but. Woodstock the film.
Woodstock.
Made quite a bit of the
sort of medical problems
that arose in in the context of bad
trips but also cuts and bruises
and god knows what all that happens
when thousands of people suddenly find
themselves together in fairly unsanitary
conditions. So i said to graham
that i would coordinate the medical
side of things for the festival.
And so i just gathered a group of.
My fellow psychiatric registrars as a matter
of fact we were all in psych training
and said you know we want to go
up to nimbin for the festival
and so we went up on a preliminary
visit to nimbin and discovered
that there was a hospital there but
it had been closed for many years
and there was just.
A sister working at the hospital sort of
keeping it open because there wasn't even
a doctor in the town it was a dying town
and too small to support a town doctor.
And we came to the base
hospital in lismore.
With very long hair and short shorts
and the ids and all the rest of it.
And beads and said to a rather astonished
administration here at the hospital
that they'd better open this hospital
up. And that we would indeed man it.
And woman it and look after it
for the time of the festival
and strangely enough despite our bizarre
appearance all that they required was
that we show evidence that
we were indeed doctors
and there they were they staff
the hospital with nurses
and i handed over the hospital to me and
my cohorts. So there i was at nimbin.
With the rest of my tribe. And friends.
I was sort of. Wandering between
the the camp that we made.
What on malcolm creek and
the hospital and so i was.
Very much there and.
More
and more i guess the idea of rejecting
the dominant paradigm and being
able to rejected both in practical
and in personal terms. Was stamped
informing so i saw myself.
I was living in group homes and
commune all houses in sydney. Anyway.
Although married me and my wife.
Both lived in houses where there were a
lot of other people living so the idea of
living with a group of like minded souls
rather than just known fahmi was.
Again stamped in for me at the
festival so i and a few of.
My immediate friends bought a
farm. While we were there.
It cost us nine thousand dollars
for the 200 acres of nimbin.
And of course the locals thought we
were absolute fools for even paying
that much money for.
This piece of dirt but we
were quite captivated with it
and we could all see that.
We did want to live community and
most of us felt that one way
or another we could probably find some sort
of employment up here certainly for me
i knew there was no doubt because there was
no psychiatric service up here in 1973.
At all. And one of the other
doctors that i brought up with me.
Decided as soon as he hit.
Town that he indeed was going
to come up here and say
and start a psychiatric service
and that he would need a friend
and a partner to do that.
So it was simply remained for
me to go back to sydney then
and qualify which i did
the next year in 74.
All and then i i was doing a
research project in sydney.
So i didn't actually come
here and start work till 75.
Although from 73 on i mean every holiday
since we had the farm up here we would all
come here and indeed one of one
or two of the people moved up
by the end of seventy three.
And so we had the farm and we
decided to live communally
and to try to share as much as we could.
So that stage.
The tribal nature of the migration
was pretty clear to me and my friends
that was what we wanted a
sense of community that.
In fact pretty actively
rejected the dominant culture.
But its very hard to reject the
dominant culture so we weren't.
I mean we decided to get onto the grid
and we indeed i think the farm was hooked
up to electricity when we bought it
and we didn't chop down a telephone
pass or anything like that.
So what we did i guess as a group of
people who were. You know capable of.
Feeling comfortable about a level of
compromise and accommodation up we came and
and joined the tribe here and.
Various of us got part time jobs and others
just stayed at home on the farm and.
We tried as much as we could to to.
To reject simple sort of nuclear
living and nuclear aspirations
and nuclear family aspirations.
And so that's how i got here.
Back to what. You.
Work in. Yes.
Oh yes no doubt
that the festival worked for
me as an affirmation of the
possibility of really feeling
a sense of belonging with a
very disparate group of people
who were indeed pretty different
from all of the groups
that i'd known before then the possible
groups i mean i could join the medical
tribe but
that had never interested me i could have
gone into politics because i was interested
in that you know at the university but
that particular tribe didn't grab me.
My parents were both successful
schoolteachers and i could have continued on.
As the fairly successful upper middle class
doctor which is what i would have liked
me to be and and move in that.
Tribe but for my for me the.
The dope smoking.
You know mushroomed eating
tribe had much more appeal
and also there. There was quite enough.
Well intellectual stimulation for
me in it. Frankly i felt but.
The group of people who i
who i was living with.
Were wonderfully creatively
intelligent and bright.
I mean they were not in any way behind
any group of people with respect to
having the sort of intellectual can't
contact that i wanted it seemed to me
that they were to the forefront
in the area of ideas in.
In in in an enormous number of areas
they were a very very rich tapestry
of human beings. There was no doubt
in my mind that they were the.
The group that i belong to and
really that i still belong to.
So the festival made it obvious
that
that tribal connectedness was available
to me provided i've migrated
and. You know hang on in through
all the the ambiguity of.
Of the thing because
it would. It would be.
It's not true. To suggest that we had an
ideology even though the counterculture.
And rosek and those sorts of writers would
suggest there was some sort of ideology.
It's not really true. I
mean basically it was to.
To not follow the dominant paradigm
i mean it was a negative ideology
that everything that anybody else was
was hanging onto was probably useless.
So.
If you do have an ideology that's essentially
a negative one which i think is what
we had with all sorts of people.
Pronouncing on their
particular positive ideology
and saying that was what it was all about.
I mean you really had to be able to
tolerate an enormous amount of ambiguity.
You know there are many people who i'm
sure you will talk to who will say
that it was abs that that name and
was about alternative energy or
that nimbin was about.
The art so that niman was about.
Smoking dope.
And indeed it was about all of those
sorts of things but i was never.
I never felt it was about
anything in particular.
Other than the rejection of the dominant.
Paradigm because and i we're you
know in my ignorance i suppose i.
I felt certain that the dominant
paradigm was a failure.
And both for individual human
beings and for the planet.
So i was confident that
that what most people were doing
was not really helping either them
or the planet but i thought what
we should do in the face of
that problem.
I wasn't too confident and i just went
along for the ride with a number of the.
The things that became. Focal points.
You know for for the new tribe. For years.
So.
I'm.
I'm just as sure as i was then which i
suppose some people would say it's too short
but i don't feel absolutely certain.
But i'm certainly about i
am as sure as i was then
that the way humans relate to each other.
And the structures through which most
humans relate to each other in australia
and indeed in the whole of the
western world are bad for
humans and bad for the planet. Yes i'm
i'm i'm pretty sure that we were right.
That most of the things that were
happening were wrong but i don't know
that we've come up with any
particularly brilliant.
Alternative structures. You know
we've had no impact on the media.
We've had no impact on.
No chel ism.
Consumerism while we've had a little bit
of an impact on those two things i guess
as a local at a local level
we've had a i think.
A leading role in alerting the planet
to the environmental consequences
of western society.
So there are things like that.
Which i think very powerful
and very very important
but apart from that
capacity to to turn around.
I think a lot of people as far as the
environment is concerned there are not too
many things
that we could say i have been
outstandingly successful in our.
In changing this terrible slide
that we're in both as individuals
and of course as a planet.
Oh no no.
I'm a bit naive i suppose
but i i wouldn't say we've
filed i would just see the.
The problems.
Of creating change to be.
Well massive i mean. There are.
In any particular system.
There are feedback loops
invisible feedback loops
that are operating to keep
things running the way they are.
And to bring about some change
in the sort of structures
that are dominating you know. Our
life at the moment i think is some.
That's that's simply beyond a small group
of people i mean i think we're going to
need a lot of luck.
Right now for for this terrible process
that we're all engaged in to
distill right i don't see.
I don't know what the media.
What impact the media have on my life at
the moment but i suspect it's profound
and yet i can't see any
why in the past 25 years
that i've been a conscious create creature
and and interacting with the media.
I can't see any way in which.
I could either find out what
they're really doing to me.
Or see how i could impact them
other than the way that i have.
So i feel pretty powerless in the
face of the media and i think
that the right word. I guess there
are forms of communication.
I suppose i should say there
are just so pervasive
and and at the same time.
Undiscerning bull unable to be
teased out into vacant pain and
that i feel pretty helpless so i don't
know that there's anything more
that we as a tribe could
have done i mean other than.
You know save the franklin
or save to rainier.
Or. Stay here.
Stay in a part of the.
Of australia which is.
Visually. Very beautiful which is not.
A city because i don't think cities
are good places for humans to grow.
So we've successfully made
a urban rural migration
and stuck around and become
useful and to some it.
Then an accepted part of that other tribe.
And now i think we've done about
as well as we could hope to do.
I don't see how else or how more
profoundly we could have impacted.
Either locally the local
scene or the national scene.
Do you think. Generations.
You know you know. Retiring.
Just go.
Well there's not a there's not
a large migration back to the
cities. So the essence of making a.
Of rejecting living in
cities remains with us.
So i no i don't think we are giving up.
I mean of course a lot of the things
that we are earlier on might
have identified as crucial to.
You know being in the counterculture
like having schooling our own kids
and those sorts of things.
Many of those ideals.
Many of us have dropped many of those
ideals but some of us still have them but.
I will always identify myself
with this tribe as long as i
can go to events where i meet
the people that i've now known
and loved for 20 years and where
we thing and then together
and smoke a bit of dope
and those sorts of things which i feel
i'm most fortunate to be able to do
most people middle class people
in a fairly upwardly mobile
sort of. Social situation have to travel
and move and make career moves and.
And i don't think that they can remain.
Usually a part of a tribe the way i've
been able to remain a part of the tribe so
for me growing old with this
bunch of people is just an
absolute treasure.
So i'll never seem like a failure to me as
long as we all gather even if it's only
three or four times a
year at various events.
But it certainly that's still happening
with a nuff frequency for me to feel
totally identified still
with the movement.
That was.
Well we. We wanted to live.
As closely intertwined with each other's
lives as we could we really did feel.
Yeah. Ok.
Well when we set up paradise
valley pastoral company.
We in our naivete i
guess we really dreamed
that we would all grow old together there.
That was the dream but rather
than being mum and dad
and the kids moving about the country
because of various people's occupations
and getting together with our brothers
and sisters at christmas time we would
stay together and live together
and work together as much as we
could and grow old together.
It was an absolutely beautiful
dream so we would eat together.
And we would buy together.
And although we'd have separate bedrooms
and those sorts of things by and large.
Our living time would be with each other.
As a small hamlet of people
rather than mom and dad
and the kids the sharing
of the money that we are
and was of course not possible.
There was really no way of.
Of exchanging money for sweat
and although in the beginning you know
i put in a lot more money than sweat
and other people put in a
lot more sweat than money.
In the long run it was very difficult for
us to try to balance those things out
and we shared less
and less money
and sweat as time went by it was
just not possible for us to
to do that dream.
And we shared less of each other's.
Commune all lives too as time went by so
gradually somebody will build a little
kitchen or somebody would
build a little living room.
So instead of having bedrooms
and everything else be shared.
Sometimes one family would eat on their
own or one couple would eat on their own.
And so commune or life.
Gradually changed into village life
and in the end that's what paradise valley
is it's now a village rather than a
commune. But the mere fact
that 20 to 30 people can actually
share the ownership of land
is not a bad feet and in the.
Even the spend what commune
or money there is on roads
and basic facilities.
Is still working there.
What paradise valley didn't have
all along was some deep spiritual
connection. And a spiritual
connectedness between all the members.
Whereas one
or two of the other communities because
paradise valley was one of the first six
two of the other six
dhammananda and body farm.
Did have a deep sort of spiritual
commitment and i felt for a while as if
that was going to maybe hold them
in a more commune all style of life
and paradise valley but in the event.
All of those multiple occupancies
have now become multiple occupancies
and they're rather. Villages
rather than anything
that people would usually understand
when they talk about a commune.
They just villagers of friends of like
minded friends with fairly similar ideals
who have a capacity to exchange sweat but.
The exchange of money for sweat
has still. I think defeated.
Most of us
when we've tried to do it.
Oh well i suppose it's it's
almost just total logical to say
that we couldn't overcome
our conditioning.
You know i i was hurting plenty
of money so i could pay some
of the people to do some
work for me and for us.
At quite a reasonable right. Per hour.
But there was no way i could pay for
somebody else to do something for me
or for the farm at the same hourly rate
that i was getting because the hourly rate
i was getting as a doctor was absolutely
extraordinary. And i certainly
didn't feel like paying the right
that i was getting. For
they are the labor.
It's possible that if i'd felt like
doing that it might have worked out
but i didn't feel like doing that
and the amount of money involved
would have been extraordinary.
It would have looked
and felt quite bizarre
but doing it any other way in the
long run didn't work either.
So in the end we couldn't do
that sort of exchange i couldn't put
money into the community purse.
Instead of working for
a day etc. Etc. Etc.
Just didn't work out like
that.
I think i did i did a
pretty good job of that.
I i worked i didn't work in nimbin
basically i worked in lismore
here. Well.
The fact that i was a psychiatrist and
indeed the only to carter for miles around.
Somehow or other didn't have i don't
think it impacted greatly on my life
and i don't think it impacted terribly
importantly on the community.
Except
that i grew to have a close
friendship with the local
policeman. Which might in the event.
I think of been quite helpful and early
in the piece. His capacity to top.
All right. Deviants.
I think was increased to
some extent by the fact
that he knew i was a
reasonable bloke he knew
that i worked in the context of my working
in the local city lismore i was a
respected and ordinary
well known all around.
I was a consultant i was a
specialist working in town.
So i was one of the sort of senior
doctors in there and even though.
You know like superman i changed into my
hippy gear once i got back to nimbin.
I think the the relationship that
i therefore had with that guy.
I think was quite helpful in his capacity
to tolerate the nsa not to try to police
the area. The way he otherwise might have.
And so i think
that would be probably the the main
way in which i as a psychiatrist.
Had some sort of influence on the
place it was an indirect way by.
In a sense giving the
policeman permission.
You know not to get his knickers in
a knot about this weird situation.
That was happening there
and of course he would have now not i
smoked dope too which would have helped.
I think in him not becoming
obsessed about about
that part of the whole process as well as
far as the community were concerned you
know the rest of the tribal concerned they
certainly didn't use me as any sort of
counsellor
or regard me as having any
particular wisdom because.